this is really an interesting one I
think I mean so I don't know what God is
doing here exactly but he's helping
ignite the sacrificial flame and that's
kind of an interesting idea I think
because you know let's say that you have
an impulse to make a sacrifice you think
well I should change this about my life
well it's like where does that come from
that impulse it's just well just it
manifests itself out of nothing so well
or you came up with it well you might
want to stop thinking about that
thinking so surely that you come up with
your own thoughts you don't come up with
your damn dreams do you they just happen
and God only knows where they come from
they come from your brain oh boy that's
a sophisticated answer they come from
your unconscious well that's not much
better at least it's somewhat better but
there are those Matan amazing dramas
take place in the theater of your
imagination at night you don't even
understand what they are and yet they
occur night after night and those things
dreams they can contain wisdom that it's
just well it just staggers the person
who has the dream once they get the key
to the dream once they remember it's
like oh look you just revealed a bunch
of wisdom to yourself that you didn't
know well where'd that come from well
you don't know how in the world can you
dream up things that you don't know
that's a tough one maybe we'll talk
about that at some point in this lecture
series because there are some reasonable
things that can be said about that but
you know the idea that there's something
that's not you young would call it the
self Carl you would call it the self
which he thought of that as the totality
of your being across time and space it's
something like that and that you know
each second that you exist is a slice
the self manifesting itself across time
and space and he thought of the the self
is partly the voice of conscience
whatever that is that helps guide you
when you have to make a difficult
decision and a difficult decision might
be well what do I need to sacrifice what
is how do I need to discipline myself
right what do I need to forego well how
do you figure those things out well you
know this picture is trying to put forth
the idea that perhaps if you had
established the proper relationship with
God before
other we've talked about what that might
mean then he would help figure out how
to get the sacrificial fires burning so
that you could stay in a proper
relationship with him across time well
that's such an unreasonable proposition
it what's the alternative proposition
well this isn't working out very well
that's for sure
you know Kate seems to be doing it I
don't know what it is it's like he says
if he thinks he can only do it himself
or maybe he wants only to take credit
for it or something like that he's not
in this grateful let's say and inquiring
grateful and inquiring posture because
that's what a perfect posture should be
it should be grateful and inquiring and
grateful is thank God things aren't
worse for me than they are and you
should be grateful about that because
they could be a lot worse than they are
man they can be so bad and inquiring
would be well I don't really know how I
could make it better but I'm I'm open to
suggestions man if I can figure out how
to do it I'll try it that's the in
that's the humility and the inquiry
that's a humble inquiry how could I make
things better it's something like that
and that's like what sacrifices do I
need to make in order to make things
better
that's a good question to ask yourself
you could ask yourself that every
morning what sacrifice do I have to make
to make things better you can decide
what constitutes better how about that
then it's not even as if it's being
imposed on you come up with your own
notion of what constitutes better you
know try to make it sophisticated should
just be better for you - that isn't
going to work very well right you you're
just going to fall down stairs if you do
that because you have to live with other
people and besides stupid anyways what
are you going to do like you can't even
nothing you can even say about that it's
so that that's the doubts the attitude
of a very badly behaved hyper aggressive
two-year-old and I mean that technically
and so you could you could ask yourself
well how I have this day that lays
itself out in front of me what thing
could I let go of that's impeding my
progress that if I let go of would make
my life better
my family's life better my cultures
life's better my being better and then
that would give you something to do for
the day wouldn't it you can justify your
miserable life because you need that
that's the whole point of the first
story of Adam and Eve what do you have a
miserable life okay what am I going to
do about that well if you just have a
miserable life you're just going to
suffer stupidly and get bitter about it
that's what happens to Cain it's like
well how about not doing that because
that seems to just take a bad deal and
make it worse how about making a
sacrifice and seeing if you can please
God and put being on track god that'd be
something to do what could be better
than that what could possibly be better
than that
well that's why it's archetypal man
because nothing's better than that
that's where it tops out so when you can
do that you can do that every day you
have to do it a little way because like
what good are you you know you're not
going to go and bring the socialist
utopia into being in one fell swoop
[Applause]
you might also think that you know one
of the things Cain might figure out here
there's a couple of things that just
aren't going right for him downwind of
the fire not the right place to blow
from and the fact that he's in hand
eloped in haze and smoke and breathing
it in and the fire isn't burning might
be an indication that he's doing
something wrong or he could be wiping
his eyes and saying Jesus what kind of
stupid bloody universe would produce
smoke like this it's like yes well
that's the more likely outcome and the
Lord said unto Cain why art thou wroth
and why is thy countenance fallen if
thou doest well shalt thou not be
accepted now that's an interesting line
because and I've looked at a variety of
different translations of this is 7th
verse here like a bunch of them because
the translation for that that's a
critical line and the translation really
matters and so I'll tell you what I
think the story is but I've been able to
figure out and I'm sure I haven't got it
completely right but it's so he asks the
God says to them if you do well won't
you be accepted what is a hint they're
right it's something like well things
aren't going so well for you so the the
first thing you might think is you're
not doing well what does that mean
you're not doing good does that not mean
you're not acting properly means it's
the hint if God is suggesting that if
you were doing properly you would be
successful I had a friend at one point
who was a very bitter person and he had
a bunch of problems and some of them
were self-inflicted and some of them
were fate I supposed he had his he had
become very very destructive murderously
destructive genocide ly destructive I
would say you could see it in his dreams
and and he lived with me for a while and
I knew him very well he was a friend of
mine from the time I was 12 until the
time he committed suicide when he was
about 40
and when he lived with me I was trying
to help him get on his feet which was
why he had come to live with me because
he thought maybe I could help him get on
his feet and he could only take
relatively low-level jobs you know like
he had some mechanical ability didn't he
didn't get educated although he's a very
very smart person he probably had an IQ
about 135 or something like that he's
very smart and so he was bitter too
because he hadn't educated himself to
the level that his education select
would have demanded so he had to take
jobs that were beneath him
intellectually and he had a really had
that real intellectual arrogance you
know because he was smart and really
smart people often come to believe that
only smart matters and if they're smart
and all that and all that matters is
smart and then the world is sort of
laying itself at their feet then they've
been terribly betrayed and and then they
cling to their intelligence which is
more like a talent or a gift like it's a
like it's an idol you know a false idol
which is exactly what it is in a very
dangerous one and get cynical about the
stupidity of the world and the fact that
their talents weren't properly
recognized and that's just not that
helpful you know because smart is a good
thing but I'll tell you if you don't use
it properly it will devour you just like
all arbitrarily assigned talents right
so you might have a talent but it's your
friend if you use it properly and if you
excuse it it will be your enemy and
maybe that's how God keeps the cosmic
scales adjusted but anyhow my friend was
a very smart person although not as
smart as he thought he was unfortunately
and and but he hadn't done what would it
be necessary with that intelligence to
make it manifest itself properly in the
world and that also embittered him
because he also knew that there was more
that he could have done if he would have
done it and perhaps more that he could
still need what I was suggesting to him
while he was living with us because he
was you know two levels from homeless by
that point was that he should find a job
that he could find working in a garage
working in a shop something like that
because he had some mechanical ability
and that he should do he should separate
himself from the arrogance that made him
presume that such a job would be beneath
him
because at that point no job was beneath
him and but more importantly it's not so
obvious that jobs are beneath people you
know because even if you're a even if
the imagine you have a job as a checkout
person in a in a grocery store you know
it's a fairly unskilled job you can be
in some miserable resentful horrid
bastard doing that job boy you know you
can come in there just exuding
resentment bitterness and making fakes
and making sure that every customer that
passes by you has a slightly worse day
than they need to right and and you know
pilfering time and perhaps pilfering
goods and being resentful about the
people who who gave you the position
because they're above you in the
dominance hierarchy and talking you know
bad things gossiping behind the back of
your co-workers it's like you can take
your menial position self-described
and turn that into a very nice little
slice of hell